luego de 40 días de búsqueda El Milagro
ocurrió los cuatro menores desaparecidos
tras el accidente aéreo registrado en la
selva ubicada entre los departamentos
del caquetá y guaviare fueron
encontrados con vida estaban solos
habían sido ellos mismos lograron un
ejemplo de sobrevivencia total digamos
que quedarán la historia la operación
esperanza se activó casi de inmediato
tras conocerse sobre el accidente
registrado el primero de mayo en la
misma participaron cerca de 200 personas
entre ellas unos 120 efectivos de las
fuerzas militares y al menos 70
integrantes de las comunidades indígenas
de la zona quienes recorrieron el área
di noche para dar con Los menores
la articulación entre fuerza militar e
indígenas obviamente ellos conocedores
de la selva mucho más que nosotros pero
esa articulación fue completamente
eficaz una un ejemplo de lo que puede
ser para el
este tipo de acuerdos de alianzas de
objetivos comunes tras conocer sobre la
noticia los familiares de los menores
reflejaron su alegría es algo que para
nosotros no nos dejaba dormir no nos
dejaba estar feliz no nos dejaba hablar
o sea para nosotros fue una oscuridad
huellas de pisadas frutas mordidas y
algunos elementos tomados tras el
accidente de la aeronave fueron
determinantes para hallar a los menores
de 13 9 y 4 años de edad más un Infante
que cumplió su primer año de vida en la
selva tras ser encontrados fueron
enviados a una base militar para ser
evaluados médicamente